Hey, Sinden, we're just getting going.
I've got to get this link to my co-host.
I saw your question.
And the answer, I haven't had a chance to get back to you.
I've just had a busy day.
The answer is, it's a two-part answer.
The first part is, the research itself was done by Dr. Dean Radin, R-A-D-I-N.
Dean Radin works at the Institute of Noetic Sciences.
He was, he had something to do with the original Stargate program.
I mean, a lot of people did.
So there are a lot of, like, people who, like, they really, they fluff up their resume now
by mentioning they were part of the original Stargate program.
But they may have had a very small role at the time.
I don't know how much his role was, because he would have been pretty young.
But it's Dr. Dean Radin, Institute of Noetic Sciences.
And the research, I mean, you're going to mostly find excerpts and articles about it,
was Dean Radin, Institute of Noetic Sciences, Psychic Gene.
And this was a couple of years ago it came out.
They haven't talked much about it since.
But if you go to YouTube, he gives, he still gives interviews about it.
He, he's fixated, you know, he, this particular individual is hard towards magic, witchcraft,
that type of stuff.
I don't know if he was originally, but he is now.
And so what he took from the research was that the Catholic Church had killed off all the psychics
when they killed off all the witches, and that that's where the gene came from.
So what I did was, and I assume that someone must have met with his team, but they didn't write about it.
So I can't say whether they're being disingenuous or, hey, Melissa, I missed you the other day.
Sunday, two o'clock.
No, I'm sure you were busy doing something.
Okay, so, I'm sorry, sit in.
Yeah, I don't know whether his team was disingenuous or not.
Because they didn't mention what the actual genetic sequence does.
And it's a mutation on the seventh chromosome.
They mentioned that if you have this mutation, you don't tend to have any psychic ability.
They didn't mention, they didn't, like, look, or they didn't mention looking to see what mainstream science says the genetic sequence does.
I did.
It wasn't, like, the greatest moment of genius in history, right?
But it's very notable to me that no one else mentioned this or attempted to do it, like, publicly.
And so as far as I know, I'm the only one who talks about it.
The second part.
The first part would be Dean Radden, a psychic gene, Institute of Noetic Sciences.
It's all over the internet, all over YouTube, articles and videos.
The second part was that I just took the sequence.
And I don't have it written down with me now.
It's available in some of those articles.
But I took the sequence and I Googled it.
And what came up was the purpose of that genetic mutation from the perspective of a mainstream geneticist is that it suppresses the expression of endogenous retroviruses.
So when the retroviruses get DNA and then they turn our genes and our descendants genes into a means of re-pumming out the virus every once in a while, right?
So, like, it's basically nature's genetic engineering.
And, like, AIDS was a retrovirus.
Whatever the origin of AIDS was, there were retroviruses prior to AIDS.
So there are retroviruses in nature.
And this genetic sequence stops those retroviruses that are in our DNA from expressing, from changing the expression of the rest of the genes.
Hey, Matt.
Let me kick you up here.
So, all right.
I'm sending you the invitation.
Okay, so what we can infer from that, and again, like I said, as far as I know, I'm the only one talking about it.
But I don't think it's great genius.
It's just attention to detail.
What we can infer from it is that the lack of psychic ability in the individuals who have that genetic mutation would be the result of the function of that mutation,
suppression of endogenous retroviruses, which would tend to indicate that psychic ability itself was not originally innate in the human species,
but is the result of one or more retroviral infections at some point.
So about 60% of the population has a normal chromosome 7, and about 40% has the mutation.
So when this first came out, someone put out a map.
So what they did was they took the 23andMe and those other genetic services that, you know, you get your genes done.
And so they took those services, and they looked for that mutation on the seventh chromosome.
And they found that it was mostly in Europe and like Asia, close to Europe, and that the closer you got to Rome, the more highly represented it was.
And when they did originally put out the map, I cannot find the map.
I was there a couple of years ago.
I cannot find it now.
I know it's in the Internet somewhere.
But.
When you looked at the map, it was like a bullseye with the city of Rome dead at the center.
So as far as they know, and this is, this isn't my opinion.
This part is, is from Dean Radden.
The epicenter or the original point of that genetic mutation was the city of Rome itself, or so close to it that you can't tell the difference.
So the rest of it is just my inference, right?
But if you, I, instead of scapegoating the Catholic Church, like Dean Radden chose to do, I just took it and said, what would it,
let's look at the differences between the Romans and the civilizations around Rome and the hyper materialism and the aversion to mystic mysticism and magic and move forward through time.
Look at the areas where the gene is more prevalent and then look at, you know, the demographics that tend to be in place in power structures, et cetera.
So like the gene is prevalent in Europe, sorry, in England, but it's not as prevalent in Ireland.
So when you look at, in America, if you look at the leadership in the US and we've been around for a long time and we have a lot, excuse me, a lot of diversity.
But when you get to the real power, the Anglo establishment, it's mostly from not just England, but the same county in England or the same old kingdom, which is East Anglia, which is actually something we're talking about today.
And that is an area where the gene is more prevalent.
So no one, as far as I know, has ever typed like leaders in the Catholic Church, but they, all the popes, except for this one have been, and the last one have been Italian or most of them have.
Right.
And Italy is where the gene is most heavily represented.
You know, all the presidents up until this point have been related to each other, except for John Taylor, John Tyler, I think.
They're all related to King John.
So there's definitely a reason to suspect that from the over-representation of continental Europeans in the American power structure and the Western European power structure as well, of course, that the gene would be over-represented in those power structures.
So you do the analysis from that, right?
You say, like, well, we know that in this particular culture or these particular cultures, this gene is over-represented, this mutation, which blocks psychic ability.
So what, you know, what can we infer from that?
So, yeah, but Dean Radden, that's where you want to look.
Hey, Matt, did you get the speaker invitation?
Yeah, I'm here.
Oh, okay.
I'm sorry.
I kept rambling on.
It showed you a listener.
Now it shows you a gene John.
No worries.
Well, yeah, no, I think it's all related, right?
But I think the top, hello, everybody.
I'm Matt.
I'm JT's brother.
I'm here to help out with the podcast, add a little structure, make it interview style, just to introduce myself.
And today, I think we're talking about a disclosure, right?
American disclosure?
Yeah, we're talking about American disclosure.
I think actually everyone who's here and probably everyone who stops by will have heard one space on this topic already, but I screwed up and didn't record that space.
There's been one in 10 I screw up and I failed to record.
And that was one of them.
So this is like the redo.
Oh, it's like a portrait, right?
Like you, you redo it, you know, the next time it's a little bit, a little bit better, right?
Yeah, hopefully.
I mean, and with these topics, there's no reason why we can't do further episodes in the future, even more well refined.
Definitely.
All right.
Well, to get started here, do you want to go with the questions or do we need any background?
I know probably some of the guests are familiar with the topic.
So do we want to dive right into the meat of it?
Yeah.
So the basic premise is that the way that Americans particularly, and Westerners in general, but Americans particularly approach the disclosure subject, is a reflection of our unexamined belief systems.
Particularly our unexamined theological belief systems.
And while American, I don't know, you know, we're loud, we're everywhere, we have a disproportionate position in the global media.
And everyone will say, well, you know, whatever Americans talk about, if it has something to do with America, it's going to be, you know, super important, right?
Because it's, because it's America.
Like we had those eclipses and everyone was making a big deal out of the eclipses we had the last few years.
Saying like, call it the great American eclipse.
People have eclipses all the time, but because it was America, it was the great American eclipses.
People make those kinds of statements.
In this case, there is a specific reason why, even though UFOs and the paranormal are a part of everyday life all around the world, you really hear about it more in connection with America.
And that's the connection between disclosure and expectations around disclosure and the experience of the paranormal and American theology.
Particularly, as I said, the unexamined stealth theology that a lot of Americans have that they're not really aware of.
All right, go for it, man.
All right.
So, is there a secret religious sect that rules the U.S., and what can you tell us about?
Great question.
You always have great questions.
All right, so, the U.S. is very close to being a theocracy.
And I know that sort of rubs people the wrong way.
And it's sort of against everything that we've been taught and conditioned to say.
But I think if you, when you talk to Europeans about visits to the United States, one of the things they'll often say is, there are churches everywhere.
There are churches everywhere.
And there's constant religious programming on the radio.
And between the flags and the churches, that's something they often note.
The way we do democracy is different to the United States.
I think, as everyone is aware here, you know, we don't have a parliamentary system like many European nations.
And our, quote, republic system is ostensibly a relic of, like, ancient Roman Greece.
But the truth is, our political system has always been an extension of our, well, specifically of Protestant theology in the United States.
And the way we're able to get around it, the way we're able to, to go through our day without thinking of it in those terms, it's become a taboo subject.
And it's become a taboo subject because of the Civil War.
So this is what happened.
So, specifically, cultural America, quote, the cultural elite centers of America, New England, New York, the Upper East Coast, through the Upper Midwest, and the Pacific Coast, and into the American Southwest, are all, and through them, the American government itself,
are, you would often hear it referred to as liberal America, blue America.
What's really going on is there is a Protestant sect active in blue America and liberal America.
Liberalism, modern American liberalism, woke, progressives, et cetera.
It's represented as a political ideology, but it's actually a theology.
And, um, how this came about, it came about in New England.
And it came about, uh, during the, well, so it started, okay, sorry, I should have had, I should have had a jot list here, but I, I took a nap instead of making my jot list.
I apologize, everyone.
All right, so, um, in England, after they started printing the, um, the Bible in English, there was, um, a large sort of, um, Protestant movement.
And, um, a non-conformist Protestant movement.
You had an Old Testament Christian movement that became the Puritans, and you had a non-conformist political movement that we remember with terms like the ranters, the diggers, the levelers.
Um, very progressive Christians, uh, up until that time, um, everyone's exposure to, uh, Christian beliefs came through what the Catholic Church told them Christian beliefs were.
And when people started reading the New Testament, they, um, that's where the, the modern left comes from.
It comes from New Testament Christianity when people started reading the New Testament and, and discovering what it actually says.
Now, I'm not making a political argument here.
I'm just letting you know what, what happened.
Um, the, the Puritan Church became dominant in an area called East Anglia and, um, eventually went on to have a revolution and take over England for a brief period of time.
Um, at that, or, or following that point, roughly around that period of time, following that period of time.
Um, when, um, when the, the aristocrats got back in, in control, um, the non-conformists and the Puritans, uh, large groups of them, um, moved to Europe and then moved to the New World in order to, um, set up a theocracy like they had roughly, uh, had, um, in England for a brief period of time.
So, um, um, New England particularly was, uh, was populated, was settled by, um, extremely religious, extremely fundamentalist Protestants.
And they were Calvinists.
Um, the Puritans were a large part of it, but also the, uh, like the pilgrims were non-conformists.
Uh, people remember them as being, uh, because of media portrayals, we'll think of the Puritans and the pilgrims as being very right-wing.
And that's not true at all.
Um, non-conformism and, and even the Puritans were a left-wing, um, or were left-wing politically and a left-wing theology.
And, um, sorry, I have a little, a moment here.
Um, I need more of a nap.
Yeah, we're, we're, we're left-wing.
Essentially, um, we're anti, um, we're against the, the aristocracy and the royalty.
And so right-wing at that point in time represented pro-aristocracy and pro-royalty.
Um, the, the Puritans and the, uh, pilgrims and other non-conformists wanted things like distribution of wealth.
And when they first came to the United States, there were a number of failed, uh, communist experience, experiments.
I'm not saying that from a political standpoint.
I'm saying like they set up communes, those communes failed and they, you know, they moved forward from there.
Um, or in the 1600s with the, um, the witch trials, uh, Salem witch trials, uh, Cotton Mather and his family, um, took the, the Puritan church and they sort of recreated it.
And they created what went on to become the church of Massachusetts.
Um, yeah, I really should have, um, let's, we might have to do this one again, dude.
Oh, okay.
So, um, basically what happened was the, in New England at the time, the, the minister was the most educated person in town.
And so, um, he was also generally the doctor and there was a fusion in New England at that time between, um, medicine and, uh, Protestant, um, uh, clergy.
And, uh, and they went on to take control of the colleges, uh, Harvard was originally a divinity school and, uh, Yale went bankrupt.
And, uh, Yale went bankrupt and the Mather family, um, got the, Cotton Mather got the funding to bail out Yale and turned Yale into a Puritan, uh, divinity school as well.
So what we call like Ivy league schools are, were originally Puritan divinity schools.
And, um, um, Cotton Mather himself, uh, he was a doctor.
He had, um, he had a, uh, a, a, a strong interest in the paranormal.
He wrote about giants, sea serpents, um, all kinds of, um, paranormal creatures in, in his, uh, works, which are mostly theological, but then he would start talking about giants for a while.
That's where the, um, sort of the fixation on the paranormal comes from that in the, in the witch trials themselves.
But, uh, Cotton Mather was the person who really fused, um, ultra Calvinism, which was the, uh, theology of the Puritans with the medical system.
He's also the first person who brought, um, vaccines to the modern world, um, smallpox vaccinations.
And he, um, by taking control of the Ivy League schools, he, he set in motion, um, a situation where, uh, uh, Protestant, um, theology would become the, um, the political ideology and the personal ideology of the students going forward.
Uh, after the revolutionary war, uh, after the revolutionary war, which is a little bit, you know, a hundred years, 150 years after this, um, following the revolutionary war, two churches were founded in the greater Boston area in Massachusetts, two religious movements, a Unitarian movement and a universalist movement.
And, um, the, um, what essentially had happened was the, um, the Puritan church had, um, moved towards, uh, or the members of the Puritan church had moved towards the belief, um, when it became the state of, uh, state church of Massachusetts, they moved towards the belief that, um, Unitarianism.
Unitarianism that there was, uh, only one God that Jesus was not divine or, um, was not a, they, they, they, they basically people were moving away from the Trinity.
And as time went on afterward that, right, uh, Unitarianism came to, um, represent the belief that all, all gods and all religious beliefs were, were all different faces of the same God.
Um, and the, uh, universalism was the belief, um, that everyone would be saved so that, uh, after you, um, that you might spend a brief time in hell, but after that you would, you would be saved.
There would be a final judgment and everyone would be saved at that point in time.
So these were separate movements at that time.
And there were a series of famines in new England that, um, caused something called the Yankee diaspora and the, about 800,000 residents of new England moved across the country.
So they moved across the upper Midwest into Chicago, uh, Illinois area, Ohio, and they moved out to, um, Seattle and Oregon down into California.
They moved into the Southwest, um, from Colorado to, uh, Arizona, New Mexico, Arizona is kind of conservative, but generally the areas we look at as being the, um, the liberal areas, the United States are, are the liberal areas.
It's because they were populated by Yankees from New England who brought with them these two beliefs, these two belief systems, universalism and Unitarianism to, to churches.
They were, there were, uh, uh, sex, Protestant sex.
Um, they, uh, they, they were strongly overrepresented in the abolitionist movement.
The abolitionists were largely Unitarians or universalists and, uh, following the civil war, uh, during the period of reconstruction, the, um, Southern politicians and, and Southern hierarchy in general was, um, set aside for a period of approximately 15 years.
There were no Southern leaders in the South.
There were no Southern leaders in Congress.
They were mostly Northerners who went down and took, um, took, um, took over running the South at that time.
And during that period, Unitarianism and universalism became the de facto religious belief in the United States of America and the de facto state church of the United States.
And, uh, uh, and have remained so, uh, from that day forward.
So, uh, and I, I definitely could have had that, that other part.
I, I'm, I'm usually better with explaining it.
Um, so basically, uh, from that day, from, from the end of the civil war, if you were a, regardless of whether you're like a, someone on the left, a progressive, um, uh, also called radicals, uh, called woke, called liberals.
Or a centrist in the United States of America, you more than likely held, um, political assumptions that were actually Protestant theological assumptions tied to the Puritan movement.
It became sort of a stealth taboo movement because the North really kicked the shit out of the South during the war, particularly at the end.
And during reconstruction, um, it was a, a, a rather brutal occupation period.
And at the end of that period, uh, there was a desire to sort of shed the memory of having a civil war, shed the memory of having conquered, you know, the North having conquered and subjugated the South.
And, and, and, and having done so very brutally.
And so no one really wanted to acknowledge the fact that what was now the de facto set of religious premises in the U S were the premises of the, of the Northern abolitionists who went down and conquered the South.
Right.
Um, so it became taboo to talk about it, particularly because as part of the transition from, uh, Puritanism into the state of church of Massachusetts,
and then into the Unitarian and universalist movements, um, which largely accompanied, um, taking, not taking over, but naturally taking control of the education system and the medical system in the United States.
Um, these ideas were, um, came to be seen as like self-evident natural ideas.
They were no longer seen as, um, one option of interpretation.
The, all theological arguments aside from these ideas were seen as debating theology.
The, these basic, the Puritan principles were just seen as, as, um, natural or normal by the time, you know, by, by our lifetime, people who grew up in Massachusetts, this is just considered to be the normal things that people believe.
No, no one goes to the day thinking that they're holding strong Protestant theological, uh, beliefs.
And as a matter of fact, if you, if you ask them about it, they, they will very adamantly argue that they do not hold any religious beliefs, generally speaking, or they'll argue that they're Catholic.
Um, but they will, um, completely deny holding, uh, these Puritan, um, Christian beliefs, but that's what it is.
Uh, as the, the medical system and the political system, medical system, political system, educational system, were taken over by people who held these beliefs, who, who held onto those positions in power, um, from, again, the 1870s.
Until 2017, this is an important point to, you know, there were Southern, uh, presidents during that period of time.
Uh, those Southern presidents during that period of time were all individuals strongly influenced by Unitarian and Universalist Puritan ideology.
Uh, the first person since the Civil War to be president of the United States who was not strongly influenced by Puritan theology is Donald Trump.
And there's an argument that he really is, but that he's playing to the, um, to poor Southerners and poor Middle Americans.
I'm not going to say whether that's true or not, because it's not the, um, not the point of the, of the, the space, the podcast, uh, this episode.
Uh, only that it is something that, that, that is, is real, that is, that happened the, the general, um, clergy or priesthood became a civil, um, became civil administrators through the medical system.
So today we think of sacraments, right?
Formerly sacramental, uh, events in people's lives.
We think of those as civil events.
If you talk to an anthropologist, they'll refer to it as the American civil religion.
Okay.
Because this, this isn't just what I'm saying.
They might not speak the same depth, but they understand that the state has taken the religious roles.
It did so through the medical system.
So when you think people used to get married in a church, but now they get married or they can be married in a church, but they can be married by justice of the peace.
You think in the context of government, but whether someone is married in a church or married by the justice of the peace, they need to first have a medical examination, right?
That is the, the, the, the only thing you really need in order to get married aside for a little money is a medical certification, certification.
Uh, people are now born in hospitals and we have birth certificates.
We're certified by the medical authorities upon our birth.
We're also, if you're a male, uh, generally speaking, you're circumcised, which, um, you know, without getting into that crazy debate, right?
That's, that's a religious act.
It's, it's not a medical act.
Uh, it's a religious act.
It's been become part of the sacramental offices of the, um, the American medical system.
So, um, we, uh, marriage, birth, death, you get a death certificate, um, filled out by a doctor.
And, um, and this is the most controversial part, but the part that's most relevant to what's happening or what has happened during our lifetimes, which is that the communion feature, the Christian sacrament of communion, going back to Cotton Mather, uh, himself, sort of the founder of the modern Puritan sect, um, has come.
Vaccination, vaccination, vaccination, vaccination is, is communion.
Um, instead of everyone, um, consuming, eating the same bread or from a Catholic perspective, eating the flesh of, of Jesus, which is what Catholic Catholics believe.
Um, everyone is, uh, instead of consuming it, everyone is injecting the same substance.
So we're, we're now, instead of consuming the same substance and becoming one community, we're being injected with the same substance and becoming one community.
And that's why, regardless of the medical arguments that people might make about vaccination, the belief in vaccination, um, is, it promotes strong, fervent, if not fanatical belief in some people and, and strong opposition in other people.
So, um, the Unitarian and Universalist religious movements unified in the 1960s into the Unitarian Universalist church.
The Unitarian Universalist church has, um, has only, has, has, has barely any members.
They've never had a president.
The Unitarian church had a president, right?
Presidents.
The Adamses were Unitarians.
I think there were three or four Unitarian presidents, but the Unitarian Universalist church has, has always been a dud.
And the reason it's a dud is that it's an attempt to basically formalize the de facto religious beliefs that everyone has.
So if you go to a modern European country, um, you don't really find the, the type of, um, religious consensus around theological beliefs that you do in the state of Massachusetts, which by the way, I think I meant, I neglected to mention this, was originally a theocracy, right?
So it wasn't a democracy to begin with.
It was a, an actual theocratic state.
And that's something that we often forget when we look at, um, American history was that new England was a, was a theocratic area.
And so these, the wars and the social changes that began in New England were religious wars, right?
Like the revolution was a religious war.
Um, you can call it a crusade, but crusade is generally associated with Catholicism.
The English civil war was the first prior to the, um, prior to the beginning of the United States, uh, the first major, um, Puritan religious war.
Then there was the American revolution, then the American civil war, and then world war one, the war to end all wars and world war two, the big one.
And then followed by the cold war.
Um, and we are in the, the opening phase of another Puritan religious, um, Puritan religious war, which is why we're seeing, um,
maybe we'll talk about that later on the, um, in the podcast, which is why we're seeing, um, the, um, assertion of, uh, reassertion of political beliefs domestically or Puritan beliefs domestically.
All right.
I know that wasn't the best answer, but I'm, I'm, yeah.
Well, it's, it's great.
And I have, uh, I have a question, but it requires a little bit of background.
Um, so if I say anything that's wrong, uh, let me know, but, but my recollection is that there were kind of like four major, uh, migrations from, uh, Britain to the United States.
Um, the first being, um, the Puritan exodus, uh, and then shortly after that, um, the cavaliers or the, the royalists kind of came in and, um, settled in Virginia, um, which would go on to become the South.
Um, and then later on there was like, um, the Quakers and after that, the, the borderers were like the Scottish, um, and Northern Irish, the, the, the Protestant Irish kind of came and settled in like, um, in Appalachia.
Um, and so that seems to align pretty well with, with what you're saying, this kind of, um, like Puritan versus, um, Royalist, Baptist, like these two different sects.
Um, cause those, the, the, those four kind of seem to converge into two that I could see as, as being like pretty similar.
Um, and I was thinking about it as you were talking, um, just kind of thinking back to the, the political party system in the United States, uh, from the foundation.
This is, it follows this pretty well as well.
And there were like in the, in the origins, there was like the federalists and the anti-federalists, which eventually kind of moved over in, in the way of the democratic Republicans, which is pretty.
Um, like aligned with, with kind of this divide that you're talking about, um, that would later turn into like a Northern Southern conflict.
Um, and then the federalists kind of like went away and, and there were just the democratic Republicans for like 20 years.
And then the democratic Republicans kind of merged into the democratic party, which we still have today.
Uh, and later there would be kind of a new emerging national Republican, you know, anti-Jacksonian party that became the, uh, Republican party, which, which we have today.
But at some point along the line, because the, the democratic Republican seems carpet party, which turned into the early Democrat party, which would have been the party, you know, of the South in the civil war, as far as I can tell versus the Republican Lincoln party of the, of the, of the North.
Right.
At some point those two, uh, flipped, right.
Because, because I, I know that I understand that the Republican presence, um, as it has been for, I mean, at least in my mind, uh, since Reagan has been very, um, I guess Nixon too, but it's been, it's been very, um, influenced by like the Ivy league.
Uh, you know, Calvinist, Northern, uh, Protestant group, right.
Um, because all these presidents are either have been Democrats or they've been Ivy league or, or, you know, Reagan was from California.
Um, that all makes sense to me, but at some point along the line, the, the, the group that would have been the South in the civil war or, or, um, you know, the Royalists, as they came over the Southern.
Sect, um, seems to have shifted from Democrat to Republican, um, at least the way that we would view it today with, with Trump in office.
Right.
And so I'm just wondering, you know, what, what happened there?
What caused that, um, flip, uh, switch to be flipped, right.
Where we kind of like had this inversion between the Democrats and Republicans.
Well, the thing with that is, um, and we try not to get too political.
Um, I try not to get too political.
So this isn't a political opinion, but the, the, the South was completely destroyed at the end of the war and completely disenfranchised.
Everything that's happened since has been sort of, uh, a show.
And generally speaking, there have been some exceptions, but you know, the Republicans had, uh, control of the country, complete control, almost complete control of the United States until, until FDR.
Um, FDR was, was from New York.
Right.
John F. Kennedy was from Massachusetts.
As was George H.W. Bush.
And, um, you know, George Bush, George W. Bush was born in Connecticut.
Uh, largely speaking, the, um, the, well, people often say we have a uniparty in this, in this country.
And they'll throw their hands up and say, it's, it's just the strangest thing.
We have a uniparty or they'll say, um, the Freemasons are behind it, or they'll say, um, they'll pick some group and they'll say that group is the reason that we have a uniparty in the United States.
The real reason we have a uniparty in the United States is that individuals who are able to, um, and those other groups do exist, but individuals who are able to, um, become prominent in politics are unconsciously selected for having Puritan values.
So there has been a flip in the, um, identity of the Democrats and the Republicans, uh, several times.
However, there hasn't been a real difference between the leadership, uh, from, uh, the 1870s until 2017.
And that's what, um, made Trump's election such a big deal is that the people who, and I'm not, I'm saying big deal as an event.
All right.
I'm not making a political statement.
Uh, the people who supported him, uh, his, uh, main demographic are individuals who have been disenfranchised their entire lives while being told that they were not.
They were, specifically, they were individuals who were told their entire lives, particularly like Southern and middle American men that, um, they had all the power when they, when they've been completely disenfranchised.
And so their experience throughout their life is one of progressively being encroached on by other people and told that they are, that the justification for it is that they have this power or dominant role in society.
But in fact, they've been in a similar, but less severe situation to the native American.
So it's all been a show.
It's, it's all just been part of the psychodynamic, the colonialist conqueror psychodynamic of the Eastern establishment.
Um, which is why, um, the presidents, the Republican presidents specifically were all people who were drawn from, um, the Eastern establishment or in Nixon's case, California.
Um, the Southerners, uh, the Republican party is the party of severity.
And the Democratic party is the, or traditionally was the party of tolerance and there is a punitive, um, resentful street, uh, in people, some people from the South and middle America because of the treatment they've received.
And because of the cognitive dissonance that results from being told to, told one thing and being treated completely separately.
Um, and I'll just close it out by saying that the, cause we're, we, we are hitting UFO disclosure here.
Um, the, the reason that, um, people in the, in the South now will never forgive, um, northerners that they have been told, uh, their entire lives that they are middle-class and that the middle-class is one step away from wealth.
That in the United States of America, um, a middle-class person can, if they have the right ability and the right luck, become a, an ultra wealthy person, a billionaire, a trillionaire even now.
And, uh, what happened in the last four years, um, after Trump got elected, uh, the, the governing consensus, the governing, um, the, the theology in this country, um, reacted so strongly against that, that, um, under our previous administration, they behaved as if they were reconquering the rest of the nation.
And in the process of doing that, they told everyone who had been raised to feel and believe as a point of pride that they were one step away from, right?
Like they would put themselves hardworking Southern man will put himself like one step away from Elon Musk.
Like I could have been there if, if my luck had been different, but for us, that's like bizarre.
Like for us, that's a crazy thing to say, but that was, that was an actual belief.
And what happened, um, in the previous administration was they were shown that no, in fact, they're not like the second class in the country.
They're actually like, they were told that a whole list of groups were above them and that just destroyed, that just crushed like the, the, uh, the worldview they'd always held.
And, um, and, um, it provoked, uh, immense resentment, uh, and they will never go away.
Right.
They will never go away because they were treated again for the first time in their lives.
So, uh, so given that, um, is the American South, you know, the last European medieval society and, and how does the South interact with, with the Puritan?
Like how do they interact with these two?
Well, that's great.
Cause you actually brought it up, right.
Uh, when you're talking about the Royalists, it is.
And a lot of people don't understand that.
That's the, the, the, the hidden secret of the civil war was that it was a second English revolution.
Right.
Um, the, uh, you often see, like you'll find in letters written from, um, Northern soldiers to their families where they talk about the fact that they're going to war to defeat the aristocrats.
This is not something that we're told these days.
It's not part of our modern American mythology.
So, um, you know, the South was dominated by the descendants of Royalist English aristocratic families.
And that was not the case in the North where the, it was dominated by the descendants of, of merchants from East Anglia.
And without getting too much into this, right.
Cause we don't like get into too, um, too emotional topic.
The slave plantation system in the South, although it was the most horrible thing, maybe that's ever happened.
Okay.
So I'm not taking that away.
What I'm saying is it was a continuation of the English estate system set up in the South, but they couldn't import.
Um, they, you know, in the, uh, peasantry had sort of become, um, urbanized and they couldn't really import peasants.
They did have, uh, a lot of, um, endangered servants, um, who were of English descent and Irish descent, but they were looking for a group that couldn't escape.
That, that wouldn't ever be freed from the, the yoke of, of being peasants.
And, and that's where the, um, where slavery in America came from.
So, um, up until the civil war and following the civil war, and this is other, there are anthropologists who've discussed this.
The fact that the American South is the last medieval European civilization or society.
The values held by the average person, um, or many people in the American South are vestigial or, um, anachronistic largely from our perspective values, uh, that were held by, um, by people in the middle ages.
And so when we look at like, why is there such a difference between the American North and South, like it's, the difference is when you get beyond racial, right?
Because, um, the big focus is on, on race in America.
When you look at the American North and South, there is a incredibly strong difference between, um, Northern culture and Southern culture, regardless of the race of the individual.
And that's what it is, is that the South has, is a, is a, a left, uh, um, not a leftover, uh, yeah, I like a leftover, um, uh, medieval civilization because it was crushed so decisively.
Um, but then only occupied for 15 years, the society, the cultural values never, uh, never changed really.
I mean, there was, they, they were disenfranchised, um, but they didn't, um, they didn't absorb, right?
You have to have like multiple generations, um, in order to absorb and take on the beliefs of an occupying power.
So, uh, the, uh, the, uh, the leadership, um, the elite in the South went to school in Ivy League schools back East, uh, adopted, uh, Unitarian and Universalist Puritan beliefs.
The average person in the South, particularly in rural areas, maintained the, um, um, the beliefs and the, um, yeah, maintained the social structure, the medieval social structure.
So, uh, prior to, um, the Civil War, the, the South was largely Anglican and Episcopalian.
So it was basically almost Catholic, very close to being Catholic and with, with Catholic areas, uh, following, um, the Civil War, what will often happen when a country is very, uh, decisively defeated is that they'll look around, they'll question their religious faith and they'll look around for alternatives.
And in the South, that wound up being the Great Awakening and the, um, beginning of non-denominational and evangelical Christian churches, which are sort of a subsect of the Baptist church system.
And, um, the faith of those churches, um, is highly the interpretation, the religious interpretation from those sources, uh, from those churches is highly influenced by the, um,
by that, um, by that, um, medieval social legacy where, um, there's a strong focus on the Old Testament and, uh, a projection of Christianity so that, uh, the ancient, um, ancient Middle East was like in the minds of, of many American Southerners.
The ancient Middle East is what was basically Oklahoma with like, uh, uh, Middle Eastern clothing, but in their minds is like very little difference.
If not, if any difference at all between the, the people of in the Middle East and in modern people in like Texas and Oklahoma.
And that's why when they interpret, um, the Old Testament and, and Christianity in general, they're interpreting it from, um, you know, the perspective of being like people from Oklahoma.
And it just creates a very, a rather Gnostic, uh, religious belief system.
That's completely at odds with, um, uh, Calvinism that's become the de facto American religious belief.
And this, this, um, strongly influences UFO disclosure.
Yeah.
So at risk of, uh, Rick rolling the audience.
How, how do we connect this all back to, to UFO disclosure?
Like what, what does this have to do with UFO disclosure?
Yeah, I know.
I know, dude.
I, I, I should have, uh, you know, the third time we do this space is going to be the best time.
I guarantee it.
The first time was actually really good.
So, um, UFO disclosure is, um, eschatology.
It is end times religious belief.
And that's probably how we should have started the space with UFO disclosure is end times religious belief.
Instead of starting with history and then working up to it, I should have started and then moved back.
Yeah.
Like the odyssey, you know, start in the middle of the action.
Right.
Precisely.
She has its structure.
Yeah.
So, um, the, during the period where, um, the, during the period following the civil
war, right.
This is hard for people to remember who don't say history, but the beginnings of the paranormal
awakening in the United States were in the 1880s, late 1870s and 1880s when there was a
series of events, like including, um, large airship sightings across the country.
So that was, it was within the memory of reconstruction that, uh, people began having paranormal experiences
and began talking about UFOs.
What we look at the modern UFO movement began at the end of world war two, but there was,
you know, the book world of, uh, war of the worlds by, um, Victor Hugo, all of his French,
right.
That was popular during that time.
And the interpretation, right.
People were talking about this, this concept that there's this idea that talking about aliens
is a modern thing.
It's not, um, there were thousands of years.
There was speculation about, um, human beings and other species of humanoids living on other
planets in this solar system.
That was a normal speculation for thousands of years.
Um, following, um, following the civil war, uh, as these two religious systems sort of started,
um, uh, deepening, deepening, uh, the way that people looked at these events, these parents,
paranormal events, um, can be heavily influenced by their eschatology, by their end times belief
system.
And by the 1950s, uh, the concept of UFO disclosure, 1950s, 1960s, uh, the, the concept of UFO disclosure
had come to take on, um, theological Calvinist theological end times, um, ramifications, uh, uh,
basically it's, it's, it's, it's the book of revelations for Puritans.
It's basically, that's, that's what it is.
It's eschatologically speaking, uh, UFO disclosure, alien first contact is part of the, the modern
Puritan end times.
Uh, when people began to have these experiences where they're being abducted, according to them,
uh, oftentimes there was a period of during the abduction that had a lot of religious imagery.
And then the end of the abduction would almost uniformly be a lecture from the aliens to the
abducted individuals saying, um, saying that, uh, look, you're, you're special, you've been
chosen, you need to go back and you need to tell people that you have to give up nuclear weapons and you have
to, um, start treating, uh, the earth better, fighting pollution.
And then climate change is that became a big thing.
That was, you know, you have to, um, tell the world they have to get ready for climate change and they
have to, uh, you have to change your, your industrial output.
You got to change the way you live in order to stop this climate change from happening.
Um, the climate change, the global warming became the part of revelations where there's
heat across the earth.
There's a part of revelations where a large section of the planet is burning up and global
warming instead of the sun global warming became the man-made global warming became the, um,
the, the reason that that was happening.
Um, the sin in the book of revelations is largely, uh, uh, focus on sexual sin, on lying and stealing
and murder, but the focus in these abductions and amongst the, um, communities surrounding UFO
disclosure was, um, is on, uh, sins against the planet.
So it's, uh, pollution or, um, supporting nuclear weapons and supporting state-sponsored violence,
warfare, um, fossil fuels.
Um, and the, um, the, the, the vision of first contact changed as time went on to become
this, um, there's a scene in the book of revelations where the sky opens up and there's a rider on a, on a white horse
and that rider on the white horse, and this is, you know, there's too much religion, but, um, for this space,
but a sword comes out of his mouth, like his, his words, um, slay the nations.
So basically the, the traditional eschatological expectation was that something will appear in the sky
and it will, it will have a message and that message will cause like a complete change, a collapse in civilization
and a complete change in like all the nations are going to be gone and all the previous values are going to be gone.
And then the final judgment comes and where people are judged on their, on their, you know, moral virtue or on their, the sins that they've committed.
And so with UFO disclosure, um, the expectation in mainstream UFO disclosure is that the aliens will arrive through first contact and, um, they will, you know, bring the message that we're, you know, just one planet out of trillions of planets.
And there are hundreds of trillions and hundreds of zillions of aliens out there.
And the whole universe has a moral order to accept earth.
And, you know, the only people who are welcome to leave earth and join the galactic community are people who change their morality in order to fit with the modern, um, American Puritan morality.
So that's, that's become the end times, um, for the, for the Puritans basically.
So, um, that's my point.
All right.
So, well, how does, like, maybe we should talk about like what each side thinks about that then?
I mean, like what, what, what is like the South, like how do they respond to this, but yeah, how do they respond?
Yeah.
So the, as like a UFO disclosure has been a thing as, um, there, there's been, um, UFO contactees,
UFO abductees and, uh, sightings, um, that have a religious quality to them.
The one thing that you'll find is that people who have a sighting of a UFO often respond as if they have had a religious experience or event in their life.
So you and I might think like, Hey, there's a weird thing up in the sky that I don't know what that is.
Wow.
That's odd.
And then go back to our daily life, but that's not the effect that it has on most people.
On most people, there's like some kind of religious transformation.
If you see a video of someone seeing a UFO, they'll often like start jumping up and down and screaming and yelling and running.
And they're just seeing something in the sky and not being attacked.
They sound like, you know, they're being attacked by the Martians.
They're not being attacked by the Martians.
They're just seeing something in the sky.
They don't know what it is.
There seems to be, and Carl Jung kind of talked about this.
There seems to be a connection between these sightings and a religious impulse of people, right?
So the South and the Baptist culture has responded to the Northern substitution of extraterrestrials for angels, basically, in UFO lore,
with a theory that, in fact, the entire phenomenon of UFOs, of extraterrestrials, of alien contact,
of whether the government has alien ships or not, of whether aliens are visiting the Earth or not,
of people talking to aliens in their dreams, aliens appearing in people's rooms, etc., is all demonic.
The interpretation is through the, of a fundamental Baptist religious theology that has reframed the entire thing as demonic.
So where you have people who are Northerners and part of the coastal elite,
or people who have those Unitarian Universalist belief system expecting space brothers to land
and to bring a revelation which changes humanity and ends time,
the Southern Baptists and non-denominational churches have chosen to interpret the whole thing as a pre-tribulation,
as a pre-end times deception,
where demons are deceiving people into believing they're aliens.
And their end time eschatology around it is that it will be revealed that the demons are aliens.
And then the people who believed them, obviously, their political and theological enemies in the North and the coasts,
you know, are going to be judged and punished for believing that aliens were real.
Because, in fact, all the people who believe aliens are real are trafficking with demons and involved in, like, Satanism and etc.
And this is actually something that penetrates the military-industrial complex,
which is highly, highly influenced by Southern Baptist culture, right?
There's disproportionate representation of Southern Baptist culture in the military.
And so as this process has been going on with sightings of UFOs and then investigation of UFOs and public beliefs about UFOs changing,
there has been a reaction within the Pentagon structure, within the military-industrial complex,
from people who hold Baptist theological assumptions,
who have worked against the disclosure,
and have worked behind the scenes against the people who are trying to promote the alien space brother Puritan narrative,
by saying it's all a demonic deception.
This goes back into the, at least the 50s, I think the 50s, could be 70s,
but I think it goes all the way back to the 50s,
with a group called the Collins Elite, apparently,
which is the term supposedly that was used by the Christians in the Pentagon
who opposed anything involving UFOs as being an occult, demonic phenomenon.
Now, on a more broad level, right,
as we're heading towards another confrontation, socially,
regardless of how it ends up, right,
anyone can see that we're in a situation now
where the North and South are in direct confrontation
in a way that we haven't been since the 1870s.
The disclosure movement is occurring.
Maybe it's political,
or maybe it's just part of the general confrontation itself,
but there's a public program to release,
supposedly release information the government has about UFOs and extraterrestrials
that supposedly, right, according to the lore,
is going to lead up to President Trump giving a speech
disclosing the existence of non-human intelligence.
And as this disclosure movement is becoming public,
both sides are asserting themselves.
On the one hand, you see Disclosure Day,
the movie put out by Steven Spielberg,
which restates the Universalist, Unitarian, Puritan,
Eastern Establishment UFO eschatology, right?
Like, it's a perfect statement of, like, they come from space,
they judge us for being violent and for polluting the environment,
and et cetera, and that's the reason that we're not able to go out into the galaxy.
And the reaction has been, right,
coming up through from the military-industrial complex,
from the intelligence agencies,
and into the actual government itself,
where we have members of the House of Representatives
giving interviews,
where, a few of them,
it's like three or four of them,
giving interviews,
talking about UFO disclosure,
and discussing the fact that the aliens are, quote,
interdimensional demonic beings.
Now, they're representing that as being, like,
like a final judgment.
No one is disclosing the fact that there is a
massive sectarian theological battle
that's taking place in this country now,
and that battle itself
is governing UFO disclosure.
So, one side,
they see aliens kind of, like,
as these, like, hippies
who are coming to judge us
for polluting the environment,
and the other side,
they see aliens as deceptive,
demonic beings
that aren't even really aliens.
They're more like spirits,
or something like that.
They're, like, more on the religious side.
Correct.
And, well, I mean,
even the Puritans who see them
as hippies coming,
it's still the religious,
they're basically angels, right?
But it's in a, quote,
secular sense, right?
So, where they've replaced speculation
about other realms
and other dimensions, et cetera,
with the idea that everything mystical
is explainable through physical matter.
And so, the aliens play the role
for the Puritans of, like, angels.
And they play the role of devils
for the Baptists
and associated churches.
So, it's basically
a sectarian struggle
that's playing out
through interpretations
of this set of paranormal experiences
that we call
the UFO experience.
and maybe you've already
touched on this,
but what is
the real disclosure then?
Like, is there something more
that's going on?
We have.
Yeah, yeah.
We have talked about it.
We talked about it last time.
We'll talk about it more next time.
Our next episode
will be
talking about
Oh, God.
I need, like, B1
from my memory, man.
Talking about
Intuitive Underground
and the remote viewers
and my work with them
and ancient sources
and the revelation
of the fact that
this is all
potentially a simulation
that we live in, right?
And the connection is
when you look at the sources,
like, the primary historical sources,
both religious
and just, like,
tablets
left over in Mesoamerica
where, you know,
not Mesoamerica,
well, Mesoamerica, yes,
but Mesopotamia
and, like,
Greek mythology
and the Gnostics
who were
the early Christians
or were
contemporaneous
to the early Christians.
from that point
forward,
the
basic
set of beliefs
they have
is that
if we are
living in a simulation
that we were put here
by an extraterrestrial force.
So, in fact,
it may seem like
there's a separation
between simulationism
and UFO disclosure,
but the truth is
simulationism
is the third
branch
of UFO disclosure.
one aligned
with neither
of the main
political theological
sects
in the United States.
And that,
yeah,
so, I mean,
they clearly
in the
ancient sources
and the modern
remote viewing data
would clearly indicate
that the
primary motive force,
the primary motive
individuals
involved in
creating the simulation
were extraterrestrial.
and so,
you know,
from that standpoint,
if we accept that
we live in a simulation,
then paranormal experiences
are,
including UFO experiences,
are a structured
form of interaction
with the simulation
itself
and part of the
program
designed by this
extraterrestrial force,
which history knows
is the archons.
The pagans
would have called them
gods
with a little g.
And I think
in modern terms,
they call them
ancient aliens
or ancient astronauts.
Right,
because these archons,
I mean,
they represent
the planets
or the planets
represent them
and,
I mean,
it was
that they were
supposed to be
kingdoms
on the other planets,
right?
That, like,
they were
actually aliens,
like,
by definition.
Yeah,
they did,
they did believe
in the ancient people
up until
very recently.
From ancient times,
from the very beginning
of civilization
up until
the 1800s,
really,
it was common,
the belief that there were
people on other planets
was common.
It's something
that if you look at,
like,
the Mormon church,
when you look at
the original
founding members
of the Mormon church,
because this is something
that really isn't taught
in history class,
right?
Because it's
very fringe.
So,
I didn't actually know this
and I actually discovered
this when I was
investigating the Mormon church
because
Brigham Young
and the early Mormon
leaders spoke
or wrote
fairly extensively
about the existence
of human beings
on other planets
in the system
and I thought,
it must be a Mormon thing
and then I found out
that it was not.
And in fact,
it was a very common belief
amongst people
even then in the 1800s.
It seems as if
the belief
that there aren't
any aliens
out in the universe
that some people hold
was a reaction
to
the
modern wave
of UFO sightings
that began
in like the 40s.
So,
it seems like
people,
a lot of,
you know,
a majority
of people
or a strong
minority people
not believing
in aliens
or extraterrestrials
is like
a hundred years old
phenomenon.
I mean,
it's like
only that old
and prior to that,
like it was
a common belief.
Yeah,
I was thinking about
the comet
3i atlas
that came through
and how it came
so quickly
or sorry,
not so quickly,
but it came
so close to Mars
and I was thinking
about,
you know,
because there was
the theory
that it could be
some like,
you know,
some kind of like
a ship
or something
like that,
right?
And,
you know,
why would it
go so close
to Mars?
You know,
it's like
scary close,
like very,
very close
to the path.
And I was
considering
that whoever
may have
launched
the comet,
like maybe
they were aiming
for a planet
that was
previously occupied,
right?
Like,
actually,
it's even,
yeah,
it's even more so
than that
because it,
after it passed
Earth,
right?
And it was close
to Mars
than it was to Earth,
but it was closer
to Jupiter
than it was to Mars.
And the,
the people
who believe,
right?
So the subset
of people
in ufology
who believe
there's a possibility
that our solar system
is inhabited
by somebody
often believe
that the origin
of those individuals
may have been Mars
or that the origin
of humanity itself
may have been Mars
because if you go back
a certain amount
of time,
it seems as if
Mars was inhabitable.
And that's,
that,
that part is
mainstream science,
that,
that Mars was
a water planet
for a long period
of time.
And then something
happened.
Right.
And there are moons,
there are moons
of both Jupiter
and Saturn
that are possible
places where
extraterrestrials
could hide,
but there's one
or two particular
moons of Jupiter
that are potentially
inhabitable
in some way,
according to some people.
Right?
And there's one,
this is again
where my memory
is going to fail me.
And I want to apologize
to everyone.
I just was crushed
by massive fatigue
today that I did
not anticipate.
So if it seems
like this,
this space was my
plan,
this was not,
this was not my
plan.
But I just got hit
by this massive
and I had to,
I had to lie down
as opposed to
finishing my
completion for
the,
for the show.
so I don't
have things
like the name
of this planet,
but there is
an ocean planet,
an ocean moon
going around Jupiter
that's covered.
I think it's
Enclatus,
but it's probably
not covered
by ice.
But once you
get through the
ice,
there is more
ocean under
the ice than
on planet Earth,
significantly more.
Europa.
Is it Europa?
Yeah.
Okay.
And it's warm.
They believe,
they don't know
for certain,
but they believe
based on the
models that the
water is probably
warm under there.
So if there's,
when we talk
about like,
if you get deep
into ufology,
the amphibious,
the potential
amphibious nature
of some of the
quote extraterrestrials
is,
is one of the
things that is
commonly discussed,
including right
now,
part of the
disclosure is
that there are
more sightings
of underwater,
unexplained objects
or as many
sightings of
underwater,
unexplained objects
or objects
coming and going
from the ocean
as there are
objects in the sky.
And some
whistleblowers
have said that,
quote whistleblowers,
right,
who knows,
or counterintelligence
agents,
whatever they are,
have claimed that
there are bases
for, quote,
extraterrestrials
at the bottom
of the ocean,
which is,
you know,
commonly speculated
to be where
they might be
hiding.
If you look
back in history
and the myths
surrounding the
beginning of
civilization,
there was a
strong interaction
recorded historically,
recorded in
legend and myth
with amphibious
life forms.
It was called
nagas.
In Indian myth,
amphibious humanoids
called nagas.
Indian myth
called dragons.
The original
Chinese dragons
were, like,
closer to a
humanoid.
And
remembered as
the
Oanis
or Dagon
in Western
myth and legend.
But there are
more.
Like,
that's just a few
names for,
like,
dozens of names
for beings
that came out
of the water
and brought
civilization.
So,
the idea
that there's
some kind
of humanoid
civilization
under the
ocean is
also very
ancient.
That could
connect to
Europa.
So,
the fact that
the 3-Eye
Atlas came
in and,
you know,
visited very
close to
Mars and
then flew
on to
Jupiter might
indicate
something from,
it could
indicate,
okay,
if you
accept the
extraterrestrial
hypothesis,
which many
don't,
for 3-Eye
Atlas,
it would
indicate that
they may be
looking for
previous
civilizations,
they may be
looking for
evidence that
previous
civilizations were
destroyed or
not destroyed,
and they may be
looking for
areas where
life could
hide in the
system as
opposed to
the Earth
where,
you know,
it's not
hidden,
it's right
out there.
That's cool.
The other
thing that I
was considering
too,
like,
if you take
a step
back from
the ufology
and just
kind of look
at the
astrology,
I don't know
if there is
solid astrology
on this,
you'd obviously
know much
better than
me,
but that's
something I
was considering
the fact
that it
moved
through,
like,
very close
to Mars
and Jupiter,
right?
like,
in my
mind,
Mars,
I think
of it as
like a
planet of
conflict
and Jupiter
a planet
of,
like,
abundance
expansion
and could
it be,
you know,
tying back
to the,
what we
talked about
last time
where there'd
be some
kind of,
like,
great conflict?
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
no,
it's a great
point.
I mean,
it's something
like,
I saw a
couple of
articles
written by
astrologists
on 3i
Alice.
I think
it's highly
speculative
and I
didn't
pay much
attention
to them,
not because
I don't
agree with
the idea
that we
should think
of it.
It's
because
I don't
want them
to limit
the way
that I
think about
it.
So,
people will
say,
or this is
one of the
ways people
will debunk
this line
of thought,
they'll say,
interstellar
objects are
always passing
through our
solar system.
It's just
that,
we've
only
recently
begun
to
detect
them.
So
it's
confabulation,
it's highly
speculative,
there's no
evidence to
support it,
there's no
evidence to
support the
fact that
interstellar
objects have
ever passed
through our
solar system.
We're just
assuming that
because we
weren't capable
of observing
them,
that they
were up
there.
Now,
maybe that's
the case.
However,
the
appearance
of an
interstellar
object passing
through the
solar system
must have
a strong
interaction with
the collective
unconscious.
So if we
start from the
presupposition that
everything is an
extension of the
collective unconscious,
that consciousness
is the fundamental
basis of the
universe,
that we're in a
simulation,
then obviously
there would be
an intense
meaning to the
three-eyed
atlas passing
through.
And comets
historically in
astrology were a
big deal.
But,
you know,
even if we
don't think of
it in those
terms,
even if we
don't think of
the universe as
being fundamentally
conscious,
just our
awareness,
collective
our collective
conscious
acknowledging
interstellar
objects entering
and passing
through our
solar system
must have
a strong
meaning.
It's definitely
not something to
dismiss at all.
It means
something.
So the fact
that it involves
Mars and
Jupiter and
what those
planets archetypally
represent could
be very
meaningful.
I'm not
prepared to make
a definitive
statement about it
because I don't
know.
but I think
it's definitely
something we
should research.
We should
definitely be
paying attention
when these
interstellar
objects come
in.
We should
definitely be
paying attention.
Look,
3-Eye
Alice came
in last
year and
when it
started,
I pointed
out that
there are
prophecies
related to
cometary
bodies,
interstellar
objects passing
through the
system.
Last week
we talked
about Alice
Bailey and
the Theosophical
Society and
their
prediction for
an interstellar
object to
pass through
in 2025 and
how they
linked it to
a Hindu
avatar,
the Kalki
avatar.
The Kalki
avatar has
also been
referred to
in some
Hindu texts
as cometary.
That idea
was not
unique to
Alice
Bailey.
It wasn't
widely held,
but it was
not unique
to the
Theosophical
Society.
And in
Native
American
prophecies,
they call
them
Kachina,
the traveling
stars.
And the
entrance of
this
interstellar
object,
we believe,
this was long
ago, 20
years ago,
30 years
ago, people
were writing
and I was
reading articles
that explained
that the
Kachinas
probably represented
interstellar
objects.
It's not my
speculation.
It is
speculation, but
it's not my
speculation.
it's a
long-standing
speculation.
And
following the
appearance of
this
interstellar
object, there
would be
changes on
the planet
in human
society.
We're only
at the
beginning or
midway through
this series of
changes.
So we
can't say
like, we
can't make
definitive
statements about
how this is
going to
end.
But are
we seeing
in the
world like
a massive
set of
global changes?
Yeah, absolutely.
Like the
way societies
interact, the
way the U.S.
interacts with
everyone else,
the way everyone
else is
interacting, the
closing of the
Strait of Hormuz,
the U.S.
talking about
taking Greenland.
I mean, just
very unusual
things have
been happening.
And, you
know, correlation
doesn't equal
causality, but
they certainly
began, right,
correlating with
3i Atlas.
Now, the big
transit of our
time,
astrologically
speaking, is
the conjunction
of Saturn
and Neptune,
which was
exact in
February of
this year.
But it was
very close to
being exact in
July of last
year, which
is when 3i
Atlas, the
knowledge of
3i Atlas broke
into human
consciousness, broke
into the
media, right?
So the
connection between
the appearance
of 3i Atlas
and that
historical
astrological
transit, a
once-in-6800
year, astrological
transit related,
6,400 years,
once-in-6400
year, astrological
transit related
to fundamental
changes in
civilization.
Like, prior
to anyone
talking about,
prior to any
knowledge of
3i Atlas, I
made spaces
saying, like,
pay attention to
whatever comes
into the news
in July, because
that's going to
be tied into
this transit.
Now, we also
have astro-RV
data.
We don't
have the
best astro-RV
data because
I don't
really have a
team.
I don't
really have a
functional
team.
And the
guys who
did the
project, there
are a lot of
problems.
But they
originally ran
an astro-RV
program, a
project, in
April of
2025.
There's a
little bit of
tension there
because Morgan
and I, you
know, ran the
first astro-RV
project in
April of
2024.
So, that
sort of
tension has
overshadowed the
results when we
talk about it.
But the
results in this
case, we're not
talking about the
best team or
the best
astrologer, but
the results of
that astro-RV
project were
talking about
an extraterrestrial
or interstellar
body of some
kind.
Maybe not
the I-Atlas.
Maybe something
else.
And also
talking about
this UFO
thing, like
disclosure,
discussions about
UFOs, widespread
sightings of
UFOs.
And it
might seem
like this is
something that's
common now, but
even a year
and a half
ago, it was
not common.
Like, it was
definitely
something that
people talked
about in UFOX,
but it was
definitely not
something that
was widely
discussed.
There wasn't
anticipation of
imminent UFO
disclosure 18
months ago.
When, you
know, the
project was
completed, that
identified that
there would be
this UFO
disclosure movement
at this time.
Now, that
project was
tied in with
the transit
of, or the
conjunction of
Saturn and
Neptune.
So, it's
definitely
connected with
astrology.
It's just
making a
definitive
statement about
how or what
it means.
It's just not
time yet.
We really
kind of have
to see how
things play
out.
I mean, it
seems to be
passing out of
the soul
system.
And, you
know, we're
past the
exact
conjunction, but
we have
another year or
two of
influence.
And, after
that, I
think we
can make
definitive
statements about
what we
think, you
know, it
meant.
Well, in
any case, if
it's true,
right, that
we're only
just now
noticing these
kind of
inter, like,
coming into
our solar
system, these
objects, right?
Well, I would
suppose that
would represent
like an
expansion of
consciousness
sort of
similar to
discovery of
new planets,
right?
Like, when
we discovered
the, like,
Uranus and
Neptune and
Pluto and we
found these
bigger cycles,
it comes back
to an
expansion of
consciousness.
So, at the
very least, I
would expect
that it would
be something
related to
that, right?
100%.
You are 100%
correct.
We're, as
part of what
we're going
through right
now, both
with the
charlatans
and the
grifters
who are
constantly
online talking
about, and
have been my
entire life,
talking about
an imminent
expansion and
awakening of
human consciousness
to, um,
people in the
UFO community,
ufology community,
whatever, who
have discussed
this period as
an expansion,
a period of
expansion and
awakening of
consciousness, who
may otherwise be
charlatans and
grifters, to
the theosophical
society 100 years
ago, identifying
this period
specifically, regardless
of their own
problems, because
everyone has
problems, right?
The, there is
an argument that
this is a, this
is a specific
period in, in, in
the Hindu yuga
cycle.
Um, there is an
argument, I mean,
the arguments, you
know, we could go
from, uh, society
to society and
look at what they
believe and what
religions believe
and what myths
are, and we can
identify this period
as being, um, of
particular importance.
Uh, it's hard to
judge based on the
complete shit show
that the world has
become, the, the
carnival circus that,
that the planet is
every day, and the
effect that social
media and the
technology of social
media seems to
have on, um,
increasing or
exacerbating the
dampening of human
consciousness.
And I'm not making
that up, that's,
like, clearly a lot
of research to show
that, and talk
about things like
memory, which is
very important to,
um, consciousness
and maintaining
consciousness and
self-remembering.
Okay, so, like,
there are, there
are forces, there
are distractions
that make it
difficult, if not
impossible, to
judge, um, if,
if, if there is
this awakening going
on.
But, but, the
presence of, um,
these interstellar
objects, three of
them, over the past
seven years, eight
years, eight years,
would, particularly
three, three, three
atlas, would tend to
indicate that there
is, in fact, this
awakening or expansion
of human consciousness.
Because you're
correct.
That's, these
objects all have a,
a, a metaphorical
and symbolic, uh,
meaning in the
collective unconscious
that's transpersonal,
it's transhuman even.
So, the, the
presence of these
objects, it's
something new
entering our world.
Right?
Like, entering our,
the, the inner
solar system.
It clearly indicates
something new
occurring with human
consciousness,
occurring here on,
on planet Earth.
I, beyond that,
I would just be
sort of, like,
picking the, the
things that I like
or I want to be
true, um,
and confirmation
bias would be a play
if I were to start
saying, like, this
is, this is what it
really means at this
point, but it
doesn't mean
something, yes.
Is something
happening?
Yes.
It's just, I can't
really see it because
it's such a, a
nightmare.
Now, there are,
there are people who
look around at the
world and the
things that are
happening and they
do see it as
evidence of the
expansion of human
consciousness.
I, I'm not
political and I,
I don't, I've
never been, um,
particularly, um,
fond of either
political side.
I'm not a member
of either of the
two dominant
Protestant theologies
that govern this
country.
So, and, and the
world by proxy.
So I can't, I, I
find it difficult to
look at the things
that are happening
and to see it as,
like, a positive
sign.
I don't necessarily
know if, if our
association of
awakening with
positive, like,
that might be,
that's highly
questionable.
Right.
So like, you can
have a awakening, we
can have an
expansion of
consciousness, but
not have it be a
hippie utopia.
Right.
As a matter of
fact, it could even
make things sort of
worse, right?
We could be more
conscious of a bad
situation.
You know, we
could be more
conscious of, of
human nature and
the flaws of human
nature.
Like, it could be
like, you know, the
expansion of
consciousness indicated
by the presence of
these interstellar
objects could be a
bummer, man.
You know, it
could be a real
bummer and that's
why we're not, we're
not directly perceiving
it because we're
expecting something
utopian.
We've been conditioned
to believe that, you
know, anytime there's a
great crisis, you
know, it's followed
by like something
really good.
Like it's just, we
just take that for
granted.
And I don't know if
history or anything
that I've studied
supports that, but
that's definitely an
assumption that people
have.
And again, that goes
back to eschatology.
It goes back to the
book of revelations.
And Christian
eschatology and
other cultures
eschatology as well
because every culture
had its own and
every religion has
its own eschatology.
And often, I think
most of the time, in
my experience, I
spent two years
studying comparative
eschatology
independently 25 years
ago.
So, you know, it
doesn't come back as
quickly as it used
to.
But I generally
remember that at
the end of the
shit show, things
are supposed to
get better.
I think that
because we've
come to believe
that during this
process, we
jump the gun.
And if we see
something that's
happening that we
like, we're like,
okay, this is the
end of history.
It's, you know, my
president is president
now and things are
going to change and
this is what I voted
for.
And when the next
guy comes in, the
other side is going
to be saying the
same thing.
But is it
possible?
Yeah, it's
possible that the
expansion of
consciousness indicated
by these objects
will be like a
positive
experience for
individuals who
are around in a
few years.
Yeah, but it
could just be this
expansion, right?
But it's definitely,
I mean, we're
having this discussion
right now.
There's an
expansion of
consciousness, right?
The fact that you
talked about it, you
know exactly what
you're talking about.
You are 100%
right.
So, I mean, I
would say that's
an experience, not
that you're not,
you're a super
intelligent guy, but
I'm saying like
that's clear
indication of the
spread of
consciousness, right?
awareness.
Yeah, we're
having the
conversation.
The conversation
is public.
The conversations
on a technology
that allows it
to be public
that just wasn't
possible 20 years
ago, right?
Not to this
extent anyway, not
to this amount,
like least
friction, right?
It's very easy.
And it's also, it
seems more
acceptable to have
this conversation,
right?
Compared to how
it would have
been, you know,
even just a few
years ago.
So, that makes
sense to me.
So, where do
you want to go
from here?
Well, I mean, I
feel like time is
a factor and we
got started about
seven minutes after.
So, we're trying
to, I mean, this
is a work in
progress and what
we're working on
right now is
disciplining
ourselves to be
between an hour
and 90 minutes.
It's obviously
going to be closer
to 90 minutes,
right?
My ideal is like
75, but it's
obviously going to
be closer to 90
because there's
a lot to say
about these
topics, but we
don't want to
go over 90
because we're
trying to turn
this into a
podcast and
you lose, you
lose a lot of
audience.
So, it's not
even like a
business-related
decision.
It's a matter
of like people,
we want people
to hear what
we have to
say and we
don't want to
disincentivize
that by making
it, we're
putting it
together in a
way.
As people who
listen to my
spaces know,
we could go
on for seven
hours, you
know, but
that's not
something that
a lot of
people who are
unfamiliar with
it are going
to buy into
right away,
right?
So, we're
working on
trying to make
it about 90
minutes.
Last time I
had, I told
everyone you can
come up and
if anyone has
anything to say,
you can come up
and talk at the
end.
X has a
feature that
lets us
change the
start time of
the space, but
it has no
feature that
lets us change
the end time
of the space.
So, what I'll
do in the
future, if
things pick up
and there are
more people and
everyone wants
to talk, is
like have a
separate space
afterwards where
people can talk
because we're
not just not
going to be
able to have
a, if there's
a subject and
people want to
come up and
talk, it's
just not,
we're not
going to, it's
going to screw
up the recording
basically.
So, we're
going to probably
end the space,
wrap it up for
the night.
And again, this
is a work in
progress.
You know, we
did start this
knowingly, right?
I want to be
clear about this.
Knowingly, as
an astrologer, we
chose this date
or this period of
time to start
the podcast
knowing that
Mercury was
retrograde and
knowing that for
some other
reasons it also
was not an
ideal time.
But in life,
right, there
are always
different,
there's always
a whole host
of considerations
to any decision.
And you try
to make the
best choice
that you can
in the
situation that
you're in.
So, we
were thinking
about getting
started earlier,
but we waited
about a month
because it was
just horrible
timing.
this timing, it
may take a
little tweaking.
We may have
to have a
relaunch at
some point.
And it may
be a little
difficult at the
beginning, both
because it's a
new thing for
me and Matt,
but also because
it's not the
best time
possible to do
something.
But if you
wait, you can
wait your entire
life for the
absolute best time
to do something.
You just pick
the best time
that's available
to you.
But, you know,
the problem,
Matt doesn't
need any work.
Obviously, he's
great.
I'm struggling
with all kinds
of stuff as
usual, but it's
important, like
getting it out
there and getting
it recorded is
the remedy for
some of the
stuff that I
face, right?
And it is, so
it's important
that I do that.
So, hey, I
really appreciate
Shane, you
coming.
Sinan, I
really appreciate
you being here.
Melissa, I
always appreciate
you and you
you're always
like the first
person who shows
up for my
spaces and I
super appreciate
that.
And when I did
the space on
Sunday and I
didn't see you
here, I was
like, oh my
God, I hope
most is okay.
So I want you
to know that I
legitimately was
concerned and I
hope that
everything was, I'm
sure that it was
just the timing
was different,
right?
But like I
legitimately
thought about
that for a
while and I'm
glad you're
back.
All right,
let's wrap it
up, Matt.
Do you have
anything you
want to add
at the end?
No, it was
great.
Thank you.
Okay, guys,
we're going to
be, because
Matt has like
a super
important full
time job and
other stuff
going on in
his life, there
has to be a
certain amount
of flexibility.
So the Thursday,
Saturday thing,
it's going to
be kind of
whenever the
best time is,
Sunday in the
afternoon, Wednesday
at night, who
knows, could be
a morning.
That's how we're
going to have to
schedule them.
So I apologize
for anyone who
isn't going to
be able to
listen to space
they want to
listen to live
or whatever,
but things will
just keep getting
better and better.
I guarantee it.
I have a strong
feeling that as
the year goes
on, this is
going to become
like a well-oiled
machine.
All right.
About 15
seconds and that's
the end of the
space and we'll
see you again
soon.